I don't know if you have heard of it -- or seen it --
It is said that you can trap your cat in a frame surrounded by tape.
Use tape to enclose any shape on the ground, your cat will theoretically be attracted to it
Based on the fact that there are now fifteen cats in my house,
I decided that I have to at least experiment to see if this can be successful.
(._.`)
( ́•̥̥̥ω•̥̥̥` )
The cats don’t have this simple shape of birds at all.
Hey...so we guessed...you know...maybe these cats have seen big winds and waves
Maybe they like a complicated shape.
(._.`)
ヽ(✿゚▽゚)ノ
...
It seems that the result is that this thing is completely unworkable.
I don’t know any of my 15 cats. They don’t like it.
Tell you honestly, we try to put some cats into the frame.
And they really want to be inside
But I guess they just think it’s annoying to get caught in the middle of the tape...
So...that's it, I am Anna Akana.
...this trick does not work.
Thanks to the sponsorship of Squarespace
Squarespace has an award-winning super beautiful web template
And all are online platform operations, you never need to download repair or upgrade software!!
If you are in an emergency, they also have 24/7 customer service.
If you need a domain, they provide an easy and unique build experience
Whether you are an artist photographer or simply want to do a powder for your cat...etc.
In short, you can create any type of website!
Start using squarespace.com today!
Enter ANNA for 10% off